alors est ce que monsieur legault
devrait donner un peu de luz dans les
mesures sanitaires à montréal il a dit
non c'est pas si on en parlait tout à
l'heure martine bonsoir je vous rester
avec moi on va faire un petit tour du
monde parce que aujourd'hui à londres où
où vit c'est au contraire au rang des
plus sévères plus difficile le
confinement parce que les licornes
europe montrent on est coach ensemble on
vient te tue l'europe connaît une
explosion des cas de co vide
le bilan g d'un million de nouveaux
carreaux seulement quelques jours selon
le directeur de la zone europe de
l'ouest
hans cloud azure
avec cette recrudescence vient
l'augmentation de la mortalité mais
aussi une pression immense sur les
systèmes de santé en france soit confiné
la situation est catastrophique comme en
témoigne ce responsable des hôpitaux de
paris à l'émission le quotidien sur les
ondes de télé monte-carlo
le pire est devant nous le pic de
l'épidémie c'est pour le 15 novembre
approximative en deux semaines ça
voudrait dire qu'on va installer des
tentes devant les hôpitaux et qu'on va
être obligé de choisir quels sont les
passions qu'on va pouvoir prendre en
charge est ce qu'on va laisser mourir
déjà dépassé en sont transportés par
avion ambulance de paris vers des
régions des cas lourds de kovy sont
inconscients ils sont conditionnés comme
des patients de réanimation donc
effectivement inconscient branché
à des appareils qui maintiennent rêve de
supports notamment vont ils apportent
même constat au portugal en allemagne en
italie en grèce en norvège en roumanie
entre autres où les restrictions ont été
augmentés plusieurs fermes leurs
frontières à certains voyageurs
provenant de pays considérés plus à
risque comme la suède qui maintient sa
stratégie sans confinement ni
restriction en espagne la pression est
de plus en plus forte pour que le
gouvernement impose un confinement
nationale le système de santé est sur le
point de craquer et la situation est
hors de contrôle
les 55 millions d'habitants du royaume
uni sont retournés en confinement pour
un mois c'est une nécessité dix-sept
hommes interrogés à londres
et ce n'est celui de rihanna et il
espère que cette fois ci les mesures
seront respectées pour éviter une autre
vague et un autre confinement et que
dubaï mais pour d'autres toutes ces
mesures sont préjudiciables
il n'en valent pas le coût économique
humain et social ici nathalie cloutier
radio-canada l'oréal alors on est pas on
est dans le même bateau et c'est bien
pire en europe qu'ici je voulais je
tenais à ce qu'on entende ce pour
relativiser malgré tout alors martine la
santé publique de montréal avait
recommandé qu'on n'ouvre les musées par
exemple les legends ça on en a beaucoup
parlé à deux mains de jim et monsieur
legault a dit non ce n'était pas une
très bonne journée pour monsieur legault
que cette fuite de ce document là qui
est assez crédible disons le pour deux
raisons je dirais d'abord il ya
clairement une divergence dans la proche
d'eux
la pandémie entre ce que pense mylène
drouin est ce que pense le docteur
horacio arruda et le document et les
précis il est bien fait une méthode fait
une douzaine de pages et madame drouin
nous avait donné des indices il ya
quelques semaines de ça sa vision des
choses elle avait dit j'aime pas l'idée
qu'on fasse toujours le yoyo là c'est à
dire qu'on a une vague on confine on ça
pèse un peu on confine à la deuxième il
voyait peut-être savoir une troisième
vague une quatrième elle parlait de nos
frais de la prévisibilité c'est ça que
son document 10 et on voudrait arrêter
de faire que des fiv est je joue par
dessus votre défi 28 jours jusqu'en
qu'on soit clair c'est un document de la
santé c'est thomas gerbet chez nous qui
le sorti ce matin sur notre site d'info
c'est un document de la santé publique
de montréal destiné à docteur arruda
qui dit on vous conseille pour chez nous
là pour montréal de vraiment d'être
moins restrictif pour ce que pour ce qui
est de dix lieux publics là comme les
musées les salles de spectacle on
recommandait pas de rouvrir les
restaurants faut être clair là-dessus
non et les terrasses pour peu qu'ils
rendent eu beau temps encore un peu la
politique d aménagement sébastien que la
santé publique de montréal recommandait
à la santé publique de québec sous
l'agoa dire deux mots c'est bien beau
mais c'est moi qui décide quoi
oui c'est moi qui décide qui est un
arbitrage qui doit être fait à la santé
publique alors que ça monte vers le
politique donc il a comme défendu
horacio arruda de pas avoir transmis le
document madame drouin jusqu'aux
politiques mais en même temps l'argument
2000 en droit de la santé publique de
montréal c'est dire ça prend des
soupapes
ça prend des endroits où les québécois
sont capables de
lâchez un peu leur four papam est bête
de vivre un peu plus normalement
et donc pour éviter donc la détresse
psychologique on constate en
augmentation mais aussi l'augmentation
des inégalités sociales donc c'est comme
si madame drouet la santé publique de
montréal font l'équilibré choses en se
disant oui on essaie de stopper la
maladie mais ça va peut-être aller un
peu mieux avec des mesures sanitaires si
bien qu'on pourrait peut-être ouvrir des
soupapes ce que le gouvernement veut
absolument éviter c'est le jeu de yoyo
rouvrir refermer rouvrir fermé alors
quand il va prendre sa décision il veut
être sûr de son coup pis sûr que si on
rouvre des secteurs d'activité ce sera
pour de bon en tout cas dans un avenir
très prévisible bon je veux qu'il faut
ajouter la mairesse de montréal monsieur
legault on revient c'est une
conversation que j'ai eue c'est que
l'ami de la santé à montréal ça va bien
les efforts ont fait beaucoup d'efforts
évidemment il n'ya pas juste le plateau
ailleurs le nombre d'hospitalisations
j'ai quand même partagé hominis le
souhait que j'avais 2 dépendamment si on
est capable de remplir sa plusieurs
critères de de donner une récompense
j'ai envie de dire ado pas se faire de
façon aléatoire puis impression qu'on se
retrouve dans cette situation encore
pire donc il faut fouiller les
parcimonie je veux qu'on prenne notre
temps mais je pense qu'il faut aussi
motivé des trous
les données qu'on a publié aujourd'hui
qui était pour hier montrent quand même
deux cent soixante et un nouveaux corps
à montréal donc la bataille est pas
gagné à montréal ce moment ci ont choisi
dans les zones rouges de garder les
restaurants les jim les salles de
spectacles fermé parce que ce sont des
opportunités de rassemblement j'ai
demandé à mon équipe de regarder la
possibilité peut-être d'un
assouplissement qui serait plus pour des
rencontres individuelles
ce qui peut paraître étonnant c'est la
séquence est classé là quand même les
professionnels de la santé publique de
montréal donc c'est ça marche par région
une demande de montréal qui recommandent
à leurs patrons arruda change un peu les
règles on peut se le permettre c'est
monsieur legault qui devient peu
l'expert c'est basique qui répond non
mais vous pouvez par contre faire ceci
cela libérer un peu d'espacé pour lui et
pour dire encore alors la science même
ou pas finalement oui puis ça pose des
problèmes pour monsieur legault parce
qu'il l'a dit lui même c'est ajoute à la
confusion comment ça se fait que la
santé publique de montréal préconise
quelque chose puis vous quand vous êtes
à québec dans vos bureaux vous
préconisez autre chose pour montréal
donc c'est ajoute à la confusion
non seulement ça ajoute à la confusion
sa place d'après ces mets de la pression
sur le gouvernement pour alléger ou
aussi à partir du moment où la santé
publique de montréal souhaite alléger
pourquoi gouvernement n'allège pas faut
regarder le calendrier par contre
monsieur legault dit pour l'instant on
préconise pas ça on recommande pas ça
mais dans le calendrier qui s'était
donné pour le deuxième cycle de quatre
semaines d'efforts de nouveaux efforts
il y avait un point de mi chemin après
quatorze jours de réévaluer donc on
comprend qu'il ya une réévaluation qui
se fait ici c'est par ici a pas de
choses a lancé cette semaine se reposer
la semaine prochaine il y en aura pas
parce qu'on arrivera justement à mi
chemin de ce deuxième cycle de 4 cela et
ce qu'ils répondent essentiellement
aussi martin c'est que quand la santé
publique nous a recommandé depuis le
mois de mars est sévère on a été sévère
comme ils le demandaient même plus on
n'a jamais été moins sévère que ce qu'on
nous demande est bon la santé publique
de montréal demande être moins sévère
puis monsieur legault répond baisse
assez tôt politique ultime ans à prendre
la décision là c'est vrai que c'est le
politique qui prend la dernière décision
et c'est vrai que le monsieur legault
par moments est allé plus loin que les
recommandations de la santé publique
la mauvaise nouvelle
de cette sortie ou en fait de ce rapport
de madame drouin
c'est que les citoyens ou bout là ils
doivent écouter et suivre les consignes
et ça c'est déjà un très gros défi pour
le gouvernement alors quand on a des
voix discordantes qui croit il ya
certainement des gens mauriac qui
préfèrent l'opinion de madame drouin que
l'opinion du docteur arruda
alors quand monsieur legault dit ça crée
de la confusion si ça va être plus
difficile pour lui de faire vraiment son
message alors là ils volent dans une
séquence où il devra réfléchir à sa
stratégie pour être capable d'équilibrer
les choses parce qu'ils imaginaient un
propriétaire de musée imaginé
propriétaires de salles de cinéma dès
des montréalais et des québécois et des
canadiens qui viennent ici ils vont dire
mais même madame domaine docteur droit
est d'accord avec nous il faut rouvrir
puis les propriétaires de jim van der
garde et a le droit il l'a dit il faut
rouvrir
alors on va justement entendre cette
extrême monsieur legault dit je peux
très content nous on y compte m6 gerbe
info qui sort des histoires c'est bon il
fonde le papier il est vrai mais le gru
dit moi je pas compte à part ça crée
effectivement la confusion veut c'est
des papiers interne pour discussion qui
n'aurait pas dû être publié en écho
c'est certain que ça amène une certaine
confusion
ce pas idéal comme situation donc je
pense que c'est important que les
discussions deviennent pas des
possibilités de modifier des mesures
parce que bon on a des débats tous les
jours sur les possibilités de modifier
des mesures mais quand on modifie des
meures eux on les annonce qu'on modifie
mesure quand on y pense mais on vient
pour mélanger tout le monde a pensé à
voix haute
alors ça s'ajoute une un élément débat
intéressant quand même sur les prises de
décision on a un avant de se quitter
mais sur le bourg parler des régions
le toucher est en train de lanaudière
nord et vit dans le sud mascouche
repentigny ça va bien dans ne va pas
bien
martin saguenay aussi il sait déjà qui
se croyait invincible finalement je
n'avais pas été touché la première fois
voici l'explication qu'on nous donne
c'est que on s'habitue avec les
consignes à montréal on les tient d'un
probablement davantage qu'ailleurs et
c'est vrai que le
saguenay-lac-saint-jean est à peu près
pas été touché moi je fais des
chroniques radio dans différentes
régions à cette union peut être pas été
touchés ils vont restaurant
régulièrement c'est pas tellement un
problème alors quand tu y arrives une
éclosion majeur dans leur région ils ont
pas les mêmes réflexes que ceux de
montréal ou de québec qui commence à
vivre qui vivent de façon beaucoup plus
stricte
oui sébastien on est inquiet très
inquiet on commet ou comment on pourra
réagir à ça parce que il n'ya pas de
plus que rouges n'ont ils pas plus que
rouge
en ontario il ya greer est après rouge
et gris c'est le confinement de mal mais
dans leur code de couleurs monsieur ford
mais le site répété le message c'est de
dire que les policiers vont appliquer la
réglementation si jamais ils trouvent
des gens qui sont en défaut de continuer
à appliquer les mesures sanitaires
c'est comme si il faut avoir peur un
moment donné pour appliquer ces mesures
sanitaires c'était le cas à montréal
dans la première vague s'apprêter le
québec qui est un exemple la situation
s'améliore dans la capitale nationale
mais un moment donné il était un peu
hors contrôle rappelez-vous du point de
presse de jacques godbout qui menaçaient
les gens de québec de prévoir de soins
dans les hôpitaux
si la tendance se maintenait ben là les
gens québec ont comme eu peur un peu
puis on est le retour donc dans des
chiffres un peu plus acceptable
il faut peut-être c'est peut-être la
prise de conscience qui vont avoir lieu
au saguenay-lac-saint-jean et dans le
nord de lanaudière
il ya aussi le fait que
le gouvernement toujours beaucoup de
difficultés avec le traçage on est
capable d'identifier où sont les
éclosions mais on a de la misère à faire
le suivi aujourd'hui par exemple le
gouvernement a mis en ligne un tableau
là où qui nous disait que 50% par
exemple des éclosions et en milieu de
travail mais ça générait 12% des cas
alors c'est un peu comme une allumette
là en fait on est capable d'identifier
quand on craque l'allumette
mais après on ne sait pas si le feu a
pris on ne sait pas jusqu'où il s'est
rendu et où il va alors par exemple au
saguenay ça c'est des éclosions c'est ça
quand même été assez large le centre
d'un coup alors ça veut dire que ça
c'est un sas étend jusqu où seuls
gouvernements encore beaucoup de
difficultés à être capable de suivre
l'allèle le feu de l'allumette vous me
fait de la peine quand vous parlez de
craquage allumettes parce que dans matin
ça me renvoie à la petite fille aux
allumettes ce fameux conte quand j'étais
petit j'ai froid la nuit de noël puis
qui finit par mourir et les allumettes
alors mais on le sait cette crise-là été
dur pour beaucoup de monde justement
plus démunis il faut le rappeler souvent
à montréal ici on a parlé la semaine
dernière le nombre de sans abri a grimpé
depuis le début de cette crise sanitaire
est pour ça qu il avait le choix
identifier des endroits pour que ces
gens là puissent aller au chaud ça fait
maintenant ça fait partie des arguments
de la santé publique de montréal les
inégalités sociales en retrait de oui on
confine les gens d'une certaine façon
ralentie peut-être la progression des
maladies mais en crée d'autres problèmes
ailleurs et il faut faire l'équilibré
entre ses problèmes et la lutte à la
maladie donc c'est l' équilibre qui
essaient de faire le gouvernement a
depuis le mois de mars mais la madame
droit de santé publique de montréal
apporte des arguments additionnel à la
lumière de la situation qui prévaut à
montréal merci beaucoup à vous dis merci
bonne soirée